Speaker 1: We are now asking a question that
a year ago I would not have been asking. And
that question is, has CNN decided to become Fox
News? What David, what are you talking about,
sir? Please explain. Well, this all started as
a result of the new CEO of CNN or president,
I guess they call him Chris Licht has been
selected as the next president of CNN. We
learned this in February of 2022. And immediately
after this was the case and we learned about this,
we started to learn about Chris Licht. We learned
that he created Morning Joe. He revamped CBS This
Morning, he revitalized this is CNN's own words.
He revitalized The Late Show with Stephen Colbert.
And he was selected back in
February to take control of CNN.
One of the statements, one of the big headlines
very quickly became CNN management is intent
on changing perception of the network.
That's from ABC News just a few days ago,
a couple of weeks ago. And as we have started
to see a number of resignations from CNN,
Licht reportedly told CNN staffers, don't
call the big lie, the big lie anymore,
saying that sounds like a Democratic slogan. So
Trump's attempt to steal the election that he
didn't win. Don't call it the big lie anymore.
And we have started to see some walkouts from
some relatively high profile correspondents at
CNN. John Harwood, Brian Stelter, Jeffrey Toobin,
John Cooper tweeted, I decided to boycott CNN
as soon as the network began its shift to the
right. It was a tough decision since I've been
a devout CNN viewer since I was in my twenties.
If I wanted to watch right wing propaganda, I'd
watch Fox. So for now, it's only MSNBC for me.
CNN anchor Brianna Keilar took some heat when she
tweeted after Joe Biden's Thursday speech last
week, which we covered, quote, Whatever you think
of this speech, the military is supposed to be
apolitical. Positioning Marines in uniform behind
President Biden for a political speech flies in
the face of that. It's wrong when Democrats do
it. It's wrong with Republicans do it. Well,
Trump did it. Two presidents do it. And you don't
always hear the same criticism. In fact, here's
a picture of Trump from 2019 doing the exact same
thing now. Okay, Bright. Brianna Keilar says she's
against it in all cases, but they didn't really
talk about it that I was able to find in 2019. So
this was another little data point in some of our
viewers and others saying there just is a shift
in feel about what's going on at CNN recently.
CNN also made the decision to hire a guy named
John Miller. John Miller, top intel official,
award winning journalist and bestselling author.
Right. CNN added to the network's roster of
expert analysts added as a chief law enforcement
and intelligence analyst. Well, Miller is
a guy who lied under oath about NYPD policy
of surveilling Muslims in the post-9-11 era.
It's kind of absurd to say we are hiring this
guy as a law enforcement analyst. So a number of
different red flags increasingly raising questions
about what is happening here at CNN. And I want
to remind people of the most important aspect to
all of this. You know, for so long, there's these
phrases that people just repeat, repeat, repeat.
Fox has left. And CNN and MSNBC are on the right.
And as I've reminded people many times before,
FOX is on the right. I'm sorry, did I say that
backwards? Fox is on the right. CNN and MSNBC
are on the left. I'm now thinking I might have
gotten that wrong before. What I meant to say
in case I didn't is Fox is on the right. CNN and
MSNBC are on the left. And as I've said before,
FOX is on the right in. A completely unhinged,
propagandistic way. MSNBC editorially has taken
a center left perspective. It's a Democratic Party
perspective. It's not progressive, and CNN plays
it closer to the middle while certainly having
an anti-Trump bias. I think that's perfectly
fine. But fundamentally, these are all corporate
media outlets with profit as their primary goal.
And that should not it should then not
surprise us when a change in leadership at CNN
potentially signals a significant editorial shift
as well, because these organizations fundamentally
are there to make money. That's what
they're there for. And, you know,
we've been accused of the same, oh.
Speaker 3: The bonus show where.
Speaker 2: You want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: But of course, that's really kind of a
joke, right? I mean, we're funded directly by our
audience because we are a progressive show. These
corporate media outlets are much more similar than
they are different, even if the type of propaganda
you see is not the same. So at the end of the day,
it's not a major shock that if CNN perceives it
can make more money by having higher ratings,
by making this shift in the direction of
the right that they would do it. We'll see
in the next few months, and particularly
in their coverage of the 2022 midterms,
how it all shakes out. Remember on September
19th, we are doing a massive membership discount.
If you'd like to be notified about this discount,
just get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com